most painful thing
I told my dad my dreams recently of
becoming a poet mmm
pretty recent and he said I said dad
this is what this is my main purpose
this is my divine purpose my spiritual
purpose this is the synchronicity and
alignment of all the interests of the
collective Stardust which is me in
ambitions this is what I need to do is
spread the words of spiritual poetry
what have you I said all this in a
speech he said huh
this nut some peanut butter he goes
that's sad
I was like ah I think you stabbed me huh
so that's that's a recent thing it's
like all of our lives that seems like us
humans are trying to find some kind of
purpose it seems like in this especially
this society it's like so individual and
so you know so disconnected that we're
always trying to find our singular
purpose and so to actually found like
you found your purpose and then be told
that that's like a worthless purpose is
like a state of worthlessness so that's
how I felt my family members calling me
skinny like bothers me bothered me
because I felt like being skinny was a
bad thing it wasn't like you know I
wasn't strong as a man and I had to kind
of and it created like a trauma in mean
I would overcompensate for that reason
and that my dad said I was a skeleton
when I was like four we were watching
football and I used to want to be a
footballer and he said you're too skinny
to ever before with a look at your
skeleton and that bothered me that was
pretty painful you know you should say
yeah yeah go will be the next Messi no
an ex of mine we always talked about not
wanting to have kids that was like our
things like those Lewin ones no we are
sure we don't wanna have kids and then
when we split up he choked me like
listen I want to have kids but not with
you and that was I think it was the most
hurtful thing someone said to me in my
life I was out weave I should caveat
this she since apologized and we've
cleared the air we talked about it I was
out and I I thought I had done
everything for my sister's head a
bachelorette party and we were out and I
was trying to make sure she was drinking
water so she remembered the night and I
don't know what I did or ahead but she
looked up and she said Patricia not
everything's about you and that was
really painful because I think
everything my whole life she's my little
sister and I've always tried to do
everything for her for some reason my
mind kept going straight to this one
thought and it was when I was in high
school and I was trying to be the school
president everyone voted and it was tied
between me and another guy they had to
do a new vote just between me and the
guy so they did a vote and the other guy
was and I lost I wasn't really
heartbroken over it you know I was just
laying off I lost and I was talking to
basically the head of the school this
woman name is and she told me completely
matter-of-factly it almost shocked me in
the moment because I knew it was the way
she was saying it was something that I
would reflect on forever and she said
yeah Calvin I don't think you would have
been a good president I think you would
be a good personality but not actually
organized enough to get stuff done and I
knew she was completely being honest she
wasn't being sadistic she was being very
matter-of-fact and when she said that to
me I was like oh and I guess it hurt
because I knew she was right and it
really I don't know why that was the
first thing I could think of when it was
the most painful thing because I knew
what she was saying was right and I knew
that though I had a good personality
I didn't have the discipline within
myself to be truly a leader at that time
in my life and I guess that's always
stuck with me because it's this idea of
you can have one thing but you should be
aware if you really don't have the other
and I didn't and that really hurt me
because I was just like I'm not I'm not
who I could be
yeah even thinking about my you know
it's sort of a mental pillar of
something that I always come back to
even now even just the fact that you
asked this on my own
man this is this is what I thought of
when I she asked me what my most
faithful memory was it's like an echo in
my mind that I still haven't gotten to
the place where I vanished and go know I
could be a great high school senior
president you know I think that I still
have a lot to work on on that side of me
and that hurts because we all want to
think that we're doing all we can you
know I don't wanna make this person
sound bad because we've made off and
it's little gift that my my sister was
really ill she was suicidal at plates
Adam was during the time I was doing my
GCSEs and I had three bad anxiety attack
before a history exam and I didn't make
it to my history exam and it's okay now
me and my mom have made up that she my
mom told me that I was faking it and
that it was [ __ ] and that I just
need to get myself together and it's
ridiculous that I'm faking something
like this when my sisters actually going
through she was just diagnosed with
anxiety
some other things so that was really
hard because then I felt like everything
I ever said and everything that I was
about was just complete [ __ ]
so very hard but me and my mom's made up
now and my sisters okay so it's so good
but that was that was really difficult
yeah oh I remember probably the thing
that hit me the hardest I was traveling
to South Africa do you want the whole
story back right yeah I was traveling
through South Africa I went to Joburg
and I saw a demonstration where people
who paid black people were demonstrating
and that wasn't so bad and then I went
from there to Pretoria than to keep her
so I went to an Afrikaans wedding and
this man saw monkeys jumping through the
trees and said oh that must be your
family and that didn't bother me either
because I expected to face racism there
when I got to Green Point in Cape Town
and I asked someone for the time because
I thought Cape Town was more liberal and
I was unprepared for that person's
response and they said get away from me
I don't have any money and it took me as
a big surprise because I didn't expect
to face racism in Cape Town on that
level because Cape Town was a lot more
freer and there were so many dramatic
things and all I wanted was the time and
I because my mobile phone had died and
that was really really hit me hard
because then I realised I was black in
South Africa the whole time I was
American or Jamaican in South Africa but
I was a black South African or or could
be considered to be a black South
African and when you realise that that
my accent I said sorry I just wanted to
know
the time me he he looked really puzzled
that he confused me but nonetheless that
was I think the most painful thing yeah
well I was dating this girl for a while
on and off we were kind of in like an
off period and I felt like we were on
the way to be getting back together I
texted her and asked her if she thought
like this was the end of our
relationship and she texted me back and
said yes and it was such a finite answer
to the question that it was just kind of
like it felt real like that was the end
of it and I guess that was the most
painful thing because it was so clear
and finite and there was no ambiguity
about it it was just direct this
relationship was over and it was you're
not worth listening to
when I was younger and I hadn't really
opened myself up to anyone before and we
were going through an argument or
something he he just said to me like
you're not worth listening to you're not
really worth my time and I was to say if
you're not really worth listening to or
if you've got something to say and
someone tells you that that you care
about and you thought about ug then
really hurts you just made me feel
pretty worthless and I already felt
worthless at the time of my life so I
was sort of just a kick in the guts sort
of that winded feeling like maybe no one
actually does care about me or be I'm
not worth anything probably to go kill
myself I don't want to be a dad anymore
someone said if I committed no one who
cared oh it missed me
someone said to me this year it doesn't
matter anyway because you will be alone
for the rest of your life anyway
Malcolm you are so self-righteous struck
a nerve quite lightly because I am a bit
self-righteous and that was 40 years ago
and I still remember it so I think the
worst thing someone's ever said to me
was probably a French teacher actually
wasn't even my French teacher a French
teacher I kicked out of a classroom and
she took me into her classroom which was
like the top class for a year group and
she sat me down on a chair and made me
face everyone else in the room and she
pointed to me and she said look at this
look at this guy right here look at this
kid right here this is one of those kids
that you're gonna see who's gonna wind
up in prison one day and it's gonna mean
nothing of his life and you know you're
just thinking wow really so yeah that
was for me that was like that's like
yeah I don't expect anyone to anything
like that to me because I was you know I
was only 15 so it was kind of like like
I said like essentially I mean energy
you think about those things a little
bit more than you think God is like it's
not where I'm going I'm gonna had in
mind so yeah that kind of starts the
most painful thing someone has said to
me is definitely I don't mention the
name but someone really close to me
before I came out as gay they were like
oh if you were gay that'd be very
point that be of the biggest
disappointment to the family and that
was easily the most liked because I was
15 years old I was like dealing with
myself in the school my friends having
to deal with telling other people and
the fact that supposedly one of the
closest people to me said that just
really like broke my heart okay it was
it was like I was having a fight with my
mom and and she was like wow and she
said something like you weren't even
supposed to like be born I don't know I
was really hurt I think I cried and she
was like no no sorry I I didn't mean it
what she said hey everyone I hope you're
doing well so recently I decided that I
want to try and do this question the one
in this episode and as many countries as
possible so this one was in London
that's one I've done Australia and the
US obviously that's the total of three
how exciting also I was hoping that you
guys would give me some suggestions for
episodes in the future it doesn't have
to be a question or a phone call series
this can literally be anything that you
think would fit well with my channel
obviously the questions in the phone
call series are what got me here and
what got you guys to my channel so I'll
continue to do those I'll never stop
making those but I do think that it's
time for me to expand into new projects
and just do things that I've never done
before that's really exciting but it's
also very scary because when you try new
things you're more likely to make
mistakes and maybe that's what has
stopped me for a while from doing
certain projects that I've wanted to do
but I've been too scared to do because
I've never done them before but I do
have a new motto and this motto was
inspired by Bob Ross I was watching one
of his videos and he said that he
doesn't believe in mistakes he just
believes in happy little accidents and
how cool is that
so yeah that's what I'm gonna say from
now on when I'm too scared to try
something new that's pretty much it
before you go if you do want to get
notified every time I put up a new
episode make sure to subscribe button
and bell next to it the subscribe button
means you're subscribed obviously thank
you
but the Bell means that you'll get
notified every time I put up a new
episode so if you want to know every
time I put up a new episode click the
bell as well that's it
thank you guys again for everything and
I'll see you soon
[Music]